ferme les
yeux et tu te
[Musique]
trouveras quand j'étais
enfant ma mère me racontait souvent une
histoire celle du démon roi et son
armée ils apportèrent le feu et la
terreur à notre
terre
mais ils furent confrontés au protecteur
du
peuple le singe
blanc te
voilà tu es une
bte dans cette ville les riches ne nous
voi pas comme des êtres humains
donnez-moi le travail dont personne ne
veut je
fer pour qui oublie quelle est leur
place ça ne se passe pas
[Musique]
bien viens pas bosser ici si tu
supportes pas ce genre de
truc chaque jour j'ai prié pour trouver
le moyen de protéger les
faibles j'ai la réponse à toutes les
prières je l'appelle Nicki
minage gros parchoc plein F
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parti
tu dois te battre pour ta mère pour nous
tous la colère n'apaisera pas ton âme
mon
fils ne m'appelle pas
[Musique]
fils il est temps de te
rappeler qui tu
es
une seule petite
braise peut tout réduire
enend mesdames et messieurs
êtesvous prêt pour le
combat
[Musique]
ouais